T
FORGET TO SET YOUR DVR.
S LAWRENCE: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT IRAN FIRE MULTIPLE MISS IT
ALSO TO U.S. CONSULATE IN IRAQ.
SENIOR U.S. OFFICIAL TELLS FOX
NONE OF THE MISSILES HIT THE
CONSULATE OWN ORE JENNIFER
GRIFFIN IS REPORTING AMERICANS
ASSIGNED WHO LIVE AND TBHEERK
THE CONSULATE INCLUDING MILITARY
PERSONNEL AND NO INJURIES
REPORTED AND REAX TO BREAKING
NEWS CHIEF AND FOX NEWS
CONTRADICT TORE JOHN HOFFMAN
WE'RE GETTING MORE INFORMATION
ON THIS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS
AND WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
U.S.?
WELL THIS HAS BEEN A REGULAR
TACTIC AGAINST PRESENCE IN IRAQ
FRANKLY FOR DECADES YOU KNOW
THIS IS IRAN WANTS THE REMAINING
U.S. MILITARY PRESENCE IN IRAQ
TO LEAVE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO INDUCE
GOVERNMENT  OF IRAQ TO DO THAT
EVEN THOUGH UNITED STATES
SHIFTED TO ADVISORY ROLE AND
IRAN IS TRYING TO DELIVER A
MESSAGE TO US.
REGIONALLY, JUST LAST WEEK THESE
VALLI REPORTEDLY STRUCK A COUPLE
OF IRGC GENERALS OR OFFICERS IN
DAMASCUS, SYRIA IRAN MAYBE
TRYING TO EXACT REVENGE AND
HEADLINERS IN IRAN ARE, YOU
KNOW, SEEKING LEVERAGE AGAINST
US AS WE NEGOTIATE WHAT TO ME
LOOKS LIKE A PRETTY BAD DEAL
JCPOA, NUCLEAR DEAL THAT LOOKS A
LOT LIKE THE FIRST ONE WHICH WAS
VERY FLAWED.
LAWRENCE: DAN, MY SECOND
QUESTION IS WHY STRIKE NOW?
IS IT BECAUSE OF THE POSITION OF
THE UNITED STATES WE KNOW WHAT
CHINA AND RUSSIA IS, OBVIOUSLY,
DOING ATTACKING UKRAINE IS SEEMS
LIKE OUR ENEMIES NOW ARE ALL --
ACTING ALL AT ONCE OR POSITION
IN THEMSELVES TO ACT.
>> WELL SEE THAT'S BEEN A PRETTY
CONTINUOUS STRATEGY THAT IRAN
HAS DEPLOYED AGAINST US SO I'M
NOT SURE THAT TIMING IS
NECESSARILY --
YOU KNOW, A HUGE FACTOR HERE.
REMEMBER YOUR NORTH KOREA
LAUNCHING BALLISTIC MISSILE TEST
RIGHT NOW THAT'S A CONCERN.
THE TERRORIST ARE GATHERING
STRENGTH AND UNGOVERNOR STATES
IN AFGHANISTAN AND RUSSIA
UNPROVOKE INVASION OF UKRAINE
AND RIPPING US OFF IN UNITED
STATES SO A LOT OF THREATS OUT
THERE.
WHEN I WAS AT THE CIA WHEN
MICHAEL WAS ACTING DIRECTOR USED
TO PICK OFF THREATS TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHEN WE TRAVELED TOGETHER IN WAR
ZONES MANY TELL OUR YOUNG
OFFICER IT IS THAT THE SILVER
LINING IN DARK CLOUDS IS THAT
THERE WAS AN IMPORTANT JOB FOR
ALL OF US TO DO ON THE
FRONTLINES PROTECTING OUR NATION
DETECTING ALL OF THOSE THREATS
TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY SO WE
COULD PRE-EMPT THEM BECAUSE
THEIR VISIT ON OUR SHOWS THAT'S
AN ISSUE WITH STRIKE AND AIR IS
EXTENT TO WHICH WE COULD HAVE
COLLECTED INTELLIGENCE ON THE
STRIKE BEFORE IT HAPPENED VERY
HARD TO DO.
AND ESPECIALLY IF THAT'S STRIKE
HAPPENED FROM IRAN OPPOSED TO
IRAN USING ITS PROXY MILITIA IN
COUNTRY.
GLANS DAN TOIPGHT GET YOUR
REACTION TO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE THIS WEEK WE FOUND OUT
THAT THE PRESIDENT AND NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNSEL DIDN'T THINK IT
WAS A GOOD I IDEA TO GIVE
UKRAINIANS THOSE JETS THEY SAID
THAT --
PUTIN WOULD SEE IT AS PROVOKIVE
IT AND ESCALATE THE TENSION
THERE.
WHERE THEY GETTING THAT
INFORMATION FROM?
IS IT OUR ASSETS ON GROUND THAT
ARE PROVIDING NSA THAT
INFORMATION?
>> SO IT COULD BE COMING FROM
JUST DIRECT LINE OF CONTACT
BETWEEN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND THEIR RUSSIAN
COUNTERPARTS THAT'S OFFICIAL
CHANNELS AND IT IS HAPPENING.
IT IS TO DECONFLICT BEEN GOING
ON FOR A LONG TIME AND COULD BE
THAT --
I WOULD EXPECT IT IS MORE LIKELY
THAT THAN CLANDESTINE REPORTING
AND IT COULD BE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY AT LEAST
IN MY VIEW GIVEN UKRAINIAN
STINGER AND JAVELIN WITH FIGHTER
AIRCRAFT IS A DISTINCTION
WITHOUT A DIFFERENCE AND EITHER
WAY USING THAT EQUIPMENT --
TO TARGET LETHALLY TO TARGET
RUSSIAN TANKS AND THEIR SOLDIERS
AND RIGHT NOW UKRAINE IS IN
EXTRAORDINARILY PERILOUS
SITUATION AND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION
YOU KNOW LOOKING BACK --
THE QUESTION WILL HAVE TO ASK IS
DID WE DO ENOUGH TO DETER
INVASION IN FIRST PLACE AND AS
SOON AS THAT IS NO WE RAN KIND
OF A LIVE TWITTER FEED OF
DECLASSIFY CIA INTELLIGENCE
REPORTING ON EMINENT INVASION
BUT WE DIDN'T HELP UKRAINE
PREPARE FOR IT AND HELP MAKE IT
CLEAR TO RUSSIA IT WOULD BE --
INVOLVED SPILLING INDOOR TO OUT
OF BLOOD AND TREASURE AND SO
THEY DID IT, AND YOU KNOW I
THINK IT IS A WAY ON CONSCIENCE
OF OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ESPECIALLY PRESIDENT BIDEN WHAT
WE DON'T DO --
TO HELP UKRAINE THAT IS --
THAT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT I
THINK, TRY TO HAVE HARD TILE
PUTTING MY HEAD TO PILLOW AT
NIGHT FRANKLY WITHOUT DOING
GIVEN THE UKRAINIANS TO MAKE
FIGHTER AIRCRAFT THEY NEED SO
MUCH.
LAWRENCE: YEAH.
BEN FORMER CIA STATION CHIEF AND
MOSCOW A MAN THAT KNOWS HIS
STUF